help me understand
we know the truth what are you referring
to what's the truth
i'm the truth that's just we know the
truth
like didn't go down and you know
everything like
me being in jail everything i went
through all the people that got on when
i was in jail
just everybody know the truth it's like
when i got out everybody like oh yeah
like
it's over for a lot of people you know
the real is here i just like we know the
truth
that's why i wanted to it's interesting
because
you know yourself and greedo i feel like
kind of really helped kick off a wave in
l.a
yeah um and i don't think a lot of
people
well like you said we know the truth i
understand what you're alluding to
but i don't think a lot of people um
understand that
fully yeah um and it's it's it was
it was bad that you know both of y'all
ended up going away
yeah you know what i'm saying i'm free
greedo but
uh now that you're out
you've seen a lot of people pop right
a lot of people who maybe borrow from
what you do sonically a lot of people
right um what is what is the like
like you didn't expect to get out of
jail no
not like that right so now that you're
home like like how do you feel about
just the
the landscape of la hip hop from when
you went into where it is now
i mean it's cool because it's a lot more
like
young people that's on now there's not
as many like older people that's like
trying to like
hog it and [ __ ] like and trying to not
like put people on as more young people
now
so i kind of like that because when i
was first rapping like i was getting
into it with all the older dudes because
they didn't want to help us out
so when i came to jail it's like all the
people that was like under me are like
you know like looked up to me they all
started getting home so i kind of like
it it's kind of cool
you know yeah there's like a whole like
wave of guys like ruchi like what's like
jay
chike like there's like and also i feel
like two was dope about the lac and it's
for the most part
for the most part it seems like a lot of
camaraderie yeah yeah
i don't run a [ __ ] for the most
part i mean it's la you there ain't
gonna be a lot like
you can't ever say it's a you know
everyone's cool because it's la this is
politics
you know but it feels like you know
you'll see ruchi jumping on records with
with j like you see everyone working
together for the most part
um that's gotta feel dope and then
obviously you're
you come home you're like you're like a
lot of these kids og which is kind of
crazy to say
yeah yeah cause i'm not even that old
but i'm an old [ __ ] now
like am i like my generation i'm old now
i guess were you um hey like i don't
know what
were you able to get access to to music
and [ __ ] while you were locked up
yeah i heard a lot a lot of stuff when i
was like
who that that's popped off since you
were in jail
like did do you appreciate their music
from from the city like you know because
there's been a lot
uh it's been a short time it's been
three years right three years
three years a lot happened yeah a lot
happening i guess uh
i want to take jay uh
like bino uh i like blast
i like it's a lot of people though like
there's
so many people like man it's a lie
there's a lot of people i mean shoreline
in them it was already probably
when i was out so uh
i ain't really like i don't know so many
people and so many people like
i don't know but that was like the main
ones that i like